[Music]
[Applause]
we have Morgan sword the Major League
Baseball vice president of baseball
operations who joins us that's a very
fancy Title Morgan thanks for joining us
let's look at what's happening so far in
spring training uh how does Baseball
look at some of these results some of
these calls and certainly the
controversial one we had over the
weekend
yeah we're thrilled so far I think we
played about 50 games on spring training
and and uh games are down about 23
minutes with more offense and you know
the reports coming out of camps I was in
Arizona this weekend are really positive
uh I think we're
um you know we're just kind of getting
through the first couple days of what's
going to be an adjustment period for
everybody you know there's some routines
that need to change and a lot we need to
do to get ready for opening day but um
early returns are great are we going to
see a a clock in every stadium so we can
follow along with the pitcher how long
he needs to take and then the hitter to
get in the box and you know be alert
with the pitcher you will yeah there'd
be five timers in each Major League
ballpark for the the fans in the stadium
will be able to see and then
um the broadcast is going to show uh the
time around this part of the score bug
all right explain to me from the
hitter's perspective
when the clock starts
sure so it's a clock that's counting
down uh and where it counts down from
depends on whether you're coming out of
an inning break or a prior pitch or a
different plate appearance but in normal
circumstances let's say within a plate
appearance with nobody on base that
clock's going to start at 15 when the
pitcher catches the ball back from the
catcher and count down and by the time
the timer gets to eight The Hitter needs
to be in the box and what we call alert
to the pitcher basically eyes on the
pitcher
um uh and then the pitch the pitcher
needs to begin his motion by zero
but I'm watching this play that happened
over the weekend the catcher is not even
in his Crouch he's he's standing up
and the hitter is maybe not fully
addressing the pitcher he's looking down
yep the pitcher couldn't have thrown
that all I mean doesn't the catcher have
to be down in his stance did they miss
this call no they made the correct call
the catcher has to be in the Box uh in
the What's called the catcher's box that
slot behind home plate where he was
um and he does not have to be crouched
but um I think that was just a again a
transitional confusion for for some of
the players but I think we've cleared it
up that uh hitter's got to be in the Box
looking at the pitcher with eight and
then we can go
um anytime after that
um what are you hearing uh what are some
of the negatives so far
you know I think that uh you know
there's a big group of players coaches
umpires uh that are learning a new thing
um and you know all of these folks got
to the big leagues under one set of
rules and and this is a change
um you know there's a big group
obviously that has some experience with
it in the minor leagues and a big group
who works fast enough where no
adjustment is required but
um you probably know the names we've
we've got some guys that are going to
need to make adjustments and uh change
their routines
um and they're doing it you know
honestly I I got to tell you I was I was
watching um games this weekend and it is
pretty crazy to watch big Leaguers who
have been doing something one way for 15
or 20 years just on a dime you know
change uh change their habits and it's
delivering a much more entertaining
well-paced game and you know we played a
game yesterday I think it had 18 runs in
it um two two hours and 58 minutes and
you know and you look around the
ballpark the fans are there it's it's
packed at the end of the game because uh
you know we're hitting or something a
little closer to what what fans want on
the game time is this the Nomar Garcia
power rule
yeah I don't know that a lot of our
younger fans would understand that
reference but uh he he certainly is a uh
um yeah he's a poster child for uh you
know some of what we're cleaning up and
I you know what I I wanted to come up
with this we're talking to Morgan sword
he's a MLB Executive Vice President of
baseball operations how about a batting
glove where you don't adjust you can
adjust it like it doesn't have that
strap you're just locked in because it
feels like these guys you know got a
nervous twitch there and try to get him
in the batter's box which I'm fine with
like I never knew why we gave them so
much air time where you got to look down
look down adjust adjust look you know
adjust your cup and you're ready to go
yeah well you know it's obviously not a
new issue trying to you know move the
pace of baseball games along but um you
know I think we this is a first uh step
into actual competitive penalties for
not taking you know for for moving too
slowly and and it's amazing how quickly
it works right I mean in our old systems
of sending people letters or asking to
play quicker uh you know wasn't uh
wasn't quite as effective all right I I
look at baseball as they're being
they're at a crossroads right now we're
looking at every other Sport and what
they're doing and you know how long it
takes to play again you know all of this
stuff but you know no shifts now
um more offense who came up with the
idea of the bases being larger
yeah that's something we've been testing
for a couple years in the minor leagues
uh it's it's primarily
um uh to address an injury issue uh to
try to create some more space around the
bases so that we reduce collisions and
ankles getting that stepped on that kind
of thing and the players are frankly
just a lot bigger today than they were
back when we picked 15 inches for uh for
the bases and in the minor leagues that
works you know injuries were down pretty
significantly but it does have the
effect of making the bases slightly
closer to one another so you know on the
margin this year you may see a couple
more ground balls but come in field hits
a couple more stolen base attempts
become successful because the base
runners got just a little
um a little bit of an advantage there
could I get one of the old bases Morgan
and can I put it in the man cave we've
got lots of them yeah you're welcome to
uh have one okay I'll come down with a
U-Haul and just pick up uh pick up some
bases also explain the pick-off move so
people are not surprised come opening
day when they're like wait a minute
what's going on here sure yeah so uh
we've had a pitch timer the minor
leagues for uh five or six years and uh
prior versions of It ultimately were
ineffective because
the pitchers figured out that you could
step off the rubber to reset the timer
that's the way it used to work right
that anytime you step off reset and the
result was games didn't get any shorter
and we didn't improve the pace and we
didn't sort of
um deliver the kind of game the fans are
asking for so this newer version of it
um limits the number of times a pitcher
can do that so he can step off twice
with Runners on base without penalty and
he can use that step off to attempt to
pick off he can just step off and take a
breath or whatever he wants
um if on the third step off if you don't
record an out if you don't pick somebody
off
um a block is called and each each base
runner advance is one base and in the
minor leagues
um again that was a very effective
change I think it closed a big loophole
that existed in um in the regulations
but also it encourages the running game
and it delivers an increase in stone
base attempts which that's probably the
play that fans tell us they want to see
more of most often in in baseball any
other rule changes we need to be aware
of
those are the big ones for
um uh for for 2023 and then this will um
this is this is a big a lot of change uh
for a sport that doesn't often make a
lot of change so
um we're uh um we've been working hard
on this and we're really excited about
it but you also have last year at spring
training where you had you know the
electronic signals or the correspondence
between pitcher and catcher that went
pretty smooth Morgan you know I thought
maybe we were going to have some kind of
Espionage you know somebody's you know
gonna tap into uh you know your signals
there uh any complaints about that from
last year I gotta tell you the the
pitchcom system has been
um uh an incredible tool for us and
particularly as this pitch timer is uh
going in I mean you think about now with
runner on second base not meeting
multiple signs and complicated sign
systems and enabling a much quicker
communication of the uh of the pitch
um has been has been awesome and we're
actually this spring allowing our
pitchers to where the um the transmitter
which actually they can call their own
pitches back to the catcher and that's
been surprisingly popular I I would have
thought there wouldn't be that many
pitchers interested in that but um we
got quite a few guys uh either wearing
it on the back of their glove or on
their belt where they can actually say
as they're walking back up to the mound
all right you know I'm going four seamer
here and uh um that on its own has sped
up the game
okay I do have a problem with this and
I'm I may get off my line guy I'm going
to let you know respectfully I bring
this up why do we allow umpires to have
their own interpretation of a strike
zone
why don't we just have a strike zone
Morgan
Oh you mean why don't we have like a an
automated well a universal you know
somebody will give you the corners
somebody gives you the high strike
somebody like why
why don't we just have a strike zone
well I mean I'll tell you we
um kind of on that metric are the best
that baseball's ever been in its history
in terms of the consistency and the
adherence to you know the rulebook Zone
um you know our umpires are more
accurate every single year than they've
ever been
um uh however you know I think the
um you know the the human being calling
balls and Strikes Back there has been
part of the game for 150 years and
um and you know our recent testing of
more automated forms of balls and
Strikes in the minor leagues has
um you know has generated some
interesting discussion about
you know the role of of the human Empire
in calling balls and Strikes and
honestly what what we've heard from a
lot of players and coaches is slow down
here guys like we like having an Umpire
back there like this is not an area
where we need to
um you know we need to jump to
um and have technology uh you know
introduced so I can have the Umpire
there though yeah but I can help him
frame a strike zone why is it when I was
in Little League it was armpits to the
knees and that's why I struck out so
much
yeah well I I don't know if you've ever
stood back there
um and watched major league pitching but
um what we ask these guys to do in terms
of you know calling these pitches that
are over 100 miles an hour with movement
against a zone that they can't see
um is on the border of human capability
I mean it is so unbelievably difficult
and it's remarkable that there is good
or good at it as they are
um and every year we seek to get a
little better and and uh and you know
they they they work hard at it they
matters a lot to them and
um you know I think we're gonna keep at
it you're you're you're you're towing
the company line you did well I think
you know you shook me off there a little
bit but that's okay I'll get you the
next time uh Morgan thanks for joining
us and uh we appreciate your time good
luck this spring training all right Dan
thanks man that's Morgan sword he's the
MLB Executive Vice President baseball
operations